Time to add another type of
data structure to the mix.
Before we dive into maps, I want to
introduce one new concept quickly.
A set is another one of these broad,
abstract concepts.
It's comparable to a list.
It's also vaguely a collection of
things, but with one big difference.
A list has some kind of ordering for
its elements.
A set doesn't have that but instead
doesn't allow for repeated elements.
You can think of a set
kind of like a bag.
You can reach in and
pull something out, but
you'll never know what order you're
getting the elements out in.
A map is a set-based data structure,
kind of like an array is
a list-based data structure.
The keys in a map are a set.
I know that's a lot of new terminology,
but
let's look at exactly what that means.
The keys of a map, like the words
in a dictionary, need to be unique.
You can have several definitions for
the same word stored in the value, but
if you had the same word in
the dictionary many times,
you would randomly pick out a definition
when you were first looking.
Thus, each key only
exists once in a map.
And a group of these unique keys
without any order is called a set.
So what are maps useful for,
other than dictionaries?
You can use a map for
a lot of things that have unique names.
For example, maybe you have a bunch
of information about Udacity courses.
You could store each
course ID as a key and
use that to look up more
detailed information as values.